hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es mal wieder ein
richtig leckeres kochrezept für euch und
zwar mache ich heute in einen topf das
ist ja erst so was mal an warmen an
kalten tagen genießen kann
weil wenn es draußen kalt ist muss man
natürlich inneren schön werden und bei
mir gibt's heute einen kartoffel bohnen
bürstchen eindruck ihr könnt aber auch
einfach die wir schnell weg lassen und
dann ist ein vegetarischer eintopf und
eigentlich auch in veganer eindruck
genau weil ich habe ansonsten keine
tierische produkte und ich sag' ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal die zutaten
und dann sag ich euch wo ihr zum
beispiel was austauschen könnt oder wo
man was noch ergänzen könnte ich habe
jetzt hier eine zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe
sie habe ich kartoffeln gar osterholz
aus der fall ist es ein grund wäre und
zwar ungefähr 500 gramm dann drei
karotten das ist ungefähr 300 gramm
ich brauche im lorbeerblatt gleich zum
würzen dann ein paar ins würstchen da
können wir einfach auch da können das
augenmerk eher special nehmen
ihr wollt auch kaufen aber die gab es
bei dem türkische metzger gartner
dann brauche ich tomatenmark tomaten aus
der dose gestückelte ich brauche ein
paar bohnen das sage ich euch gleich
noch was dazu und ich brauche was das
obwohl ich kein noch chili und minze und
thymian und eventuell etwas wasser
wasser wasser wasser und ich werde jetzt
erstmal mein gemüse schälen und klein
schneiden
ich brauche ja auch noch wissen olivenöl
das habe ich auch jetzt vergessen
herauszustellen
aber das machen wir gleich
uns war nicht einfach die karten und die
kartoffeln
jetzt kann ich das ganze gemüse klein
schneiden die zwiebel wette ich jetzt
fein würfeln
das mache ich jetzt hier einfach
irgendeine strecke gerät geht aber auch
ein messer einfach richtig feine würfel
und die knoblauchzehe die werde ich
jetzt heute nur halbieren
damit sie eben den geschmack abgibt und
später nämlich sehr da raus dann
schimpft mein mann nämlich nach
vorarlberg stünden ich habe geld
naja jetzt habe ich nicht dass ein auto
zusammen die conzzeta auf dem boot
jetzt nehme ich meinen olivenöl und gibt
es in meinem kopf den habe ich jetzt
bereit erhitzt ich nehme da geradezu
zwei esslöffel olivenöl und gibt als die
zwiebelwürfel mit rein und die
knoblauchzehen und lass dir jetzt bei
mittlerer stufe ein bisschen glasig
dünsten
und die zwischenzeit mit sich jetzt um
eine kartoffel einzuwirken
das mache ich jetzt auch da drin aber
mit dem anderen auch sagt und zwar habe
ich da auch einen aufsatz mit 1 cm
würfeln und es ist jetzt noch drin
und selbst den deckel richtig trauen
und jetzt werde ich mir die kartoffeln
einfach halbieren und dann habe ich so
wie sowieso keine stifte hier ab und zu
hören
die kamera besitzt übrigens ohne kamera
machen würde dann würde ich mein ganzes
gemüse in der küchenmaschine klein
schneiden
also ob die zwiebeln gleich die karotten
schneide ich nicht schreiben aber ich
bin es euch einfach auch mal so zeigen
weil hat dann hat jeder eine
küchenmaschine und und die karotten
schneide ich jetzt in scheiben und wie
gesagt können das ganz gut in der
küchenmaschine machen weil sie dann
einfach gleichmäßig dick werden hat sich
die werden jetzt von mir so über 310 mm
dick wieso ich bin sowieso aber auch bis
also genau die dürfen hat zu weich werde
irgendwann in 30 jahren müssen wir noch
weiter öffnen
jetzt gebe ich zu den zwiebeln tomaten
markt mit dazu ich habe es übrigens
immer hier somit öl drüber also so
konserviere ich das dann also wir mal
dahingestellt darf praktisch keinen
tomatenmark frei herumliegen an der luft
dann jetzt schneller schlecht und so
kann das konservieren
man fühlt sich einfach immer wieder mit
ganz einfach sind abschöpfen und wird
rein geben
da nehme ich jetzt etwa zwei esslöffel
fällt mir alle versand- und das lasse
ich jetzt ein bisschen mitbraten
und dann lösche ich das ganze mit den
tomaten ab
und schön diese dose auch mit etwas
wasser aus und füllt dann so ungefähr
einen halben liter wasser macht und das
lasse ich jetzt einmal aufkochen und so
kocht gebe ich dann die karotten und die
kartoffel mit rein
deswegen gebe ich jetzt mal kurz im
deckel drauf das ist schneller geht und
in der zeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
meine bohnen abgießen also heute in wien
ein ganz blöder tag kann ich die bohnen
abgießen und vor habe ich da jetzt
einfach fertig gekochten bohnen weil wir
mal mit ronan kocht muss man sehr
entweder also die trockenen boden nehmen
und musste dann einen tag vorher
einlegen und dann abkochen und dann kann
man sie benutzen
aber mir ist eigentlich nicht so oft
bohne und wir sind auch keine große
familie
xing lohnt sich für mich nicht die bohne
einzulegen deswegen nehme ich einfach
schon abgekocht und die werde ich jetzt
einfach kurz abgießen und mit kaltem
wasser abspülen nämlich einfach so einem
fall oder normales gibt es da rein und
stimmt einfach
mehr
jetzt kocht die brühe und jetzt kann ich
einfach das gemüse mit reingeben ganz
vorsichtig wir müssen es gleich nochmal
aufkochen lassen und wenn ihr merkt dass
die flüssigkeit zu wenig wert gibt da
einfach immer wieder wasser nach ich
würde das ganze jetzt auch schon mal
dann kommt noch salz dazu teelöffel voll
und dann einfach vom rest auch so ein
bisschen also chili mag ich ganz gern
aber ich denke auch wenn man meine
mitmenschen deswegen den kindergruppen
und noch lieber weniger pro block 1
das wird dann im mitmenschen so einiges
erleichtern und von thymian und minze
nehme man aus einem teelöffel voll und
natürlich mein lorbeerblatt und jetzt
lasse ich das ganze noch einmal
aufkochen ich geb dir jetzt auch gleich
nummer hat den deckel drauf und kann
dann in der zwischenzeit schon mal meine
würstchen klein schneiden und die kommen
dann so kurz vor ende mit haben also in
den letzten zehn minuten
die dürfen jetzt hier so etwa 15 minuten
lang kochen dann sollte das gemüse kommt
so ein bisschen bissfest sein und ich
bereit schon mal unser budget gibt es
nämlich heute mit dazu und dann sehen
wir gleich wieder
die kartoffel nach der karotten sind
jetzt fast gar also diesen grad so
richtig schön bissfest war laut jetzt
gebe ich hier die bohne mit rein
ich glaube ich nicht komplett alle und
auch die würstchen und dann muss ich das
ganze einfach nur mal so zwei drei
minuten lang kochen so und ich glaube
ich muss gleich noch flüssigkeit dazu
geben
und weil es einfach noch mal abschminken
am besten rührt ihr auch nicht so viel
damit sich einfach ist gemüse einfach
schön ganz bleibt und dass netzer fremd
und das brauche ich jetzt nur mal kurz
auf und dann kann man es gleich
servieren
mein eindruck bis jetzt fertig gekocht
und ich werde es jedes lorbeerblatt noch
entfernen also falls ihr das findet
können dass eine frau zwischen die
knoblauchzehen finde ich jetzt grad aber
ich hoffe genannten nicht bei mir auf
dem teller wahrscheinlich landes am
montag räume und ich schmeckt das ganze
jetzt noch bis hin mit zitronensaft ab
das finde ich rundet das ganze so ein
bisschen ab also gerade zum kleinen
spricht und dann müsste einfach
abschmecken ob salz pfeffer und so
weiter alles genug ist ansonsten gibt
einfach noch ein bisschen kräuter und
gewürze mit dazu und jetzt kann ich das
ganze schon servieren und ich habe jetzt
etwa für das gericht so ungefähr 30 35
minuten vielleicht auch 40 gebraucht
und ich finde es darf auf jeden fall
nicht so flüssig sein der das ganze jahr
eindruck von keine zukunft und wer
möchte kann jetzt noch ein bisschen
frische petersilie nehme schneidig und
weiter als einfach mal bisschen drüber
schneiden finde ich passt auch perfekt
mit dazu erst so richtig so richtige
landmanns kosten ja so auf eine schnitte
und ja und ich servierte das ganze jetzt
hier so etwas paket brot so lassen wir
uns selbst gleich schmecken
da war ich gleich probieren natürlich
mache ich denn frische teller dann gebt
mir den hässlichen tellers nur schmecken
muss schmecken aber du kriegst
petersilie frische kräuter immer ganz
groß
ihr habt uns auch gerade neulich doch
immer so eine fertigpizza kauft nur auf
der fertigpizza steht frische kräuter
drauf dann kaufen es die leute eher ja
das stimmt
na weil sie denken ist dass gesundes so
jetzt kriegt man einen löffel aber das
ganze ist noch ziemlich heiß und ich
hatte vorhin gesagt dass er darauf
sachen ergänzen könnte oder einfach
weglassen könnt ihr könnt einfach je
nachdem was für gemüse ihr zuhause habt
einfach alles mit rein geben also dass
ich praktisch sonja wie so ein
grundrezept mit der tomatensauce und
dann kann man wirklich alles mit
dazugeben man könnte auto vornehmen oder
kichererbsen stadt wohnen und moral ich
weiß richtig heiß und was heute bei mir
aber noch gefehlt hat und das finde ich
auch so ein absoluter kick and rush und
natürlich super kombi damit wären
paprika mix ein bisschen schafe und das
kann man da auch mit dazu geben gibt es
in türkischen und mir es gibt aber das
kommt auch aus dem ausland
er stimmt es gibt es darum bei zahlen
das sie seit überall ja wir haben wir
lassen uns heute schmecken und das
rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auf sell
list blog.de und ich freue mich wieder
aufs nächste mal